oh spins away Nate is watching him closely cross
eyes pass for Holstrom Holstrom fires it on
through grabbed by AO down the wall Sebastian AO
to the front with a back hand that one right off
the mat of Roma GL down by barzell he's able
to hold the zone now he spins on AO plays it
deep it gets all the way through for Anders
Lee bump lower for horac Brady Shay kick at
it six players all below the goal line and pop
free for barzel in front the back hand turned
aside by R the catch off to Brady Shay and then
barzel just continues to go I mean boy oh boy
Paul Murray will shoot it in he took a hard hit
from slaven though and they both go down Nelson
in and it's stopped by r two for Rin what a move
by there's number 29 for we got from Brock okay
there it was the stick left it in the neutral zone
had to group on it doson forv that barzel here's
barzel quick turn to the board barzel opens
up doson doson cruising back hand [Applause]
score no adoption at four on four on the helper
from Matt barzel great work along the boards
barzel picks up the loose Puck and he's just
on his game more adoption to his back hand
Waits and waits gets past the go CER get past
the Checker barzal has just been unbelievable
knows when to pass it when not to pass it look at
the fake P the p and then wait wait wait open it
up Brey top of the circle down to
the goal line coachi in front off
the outside of the net vet Toom
a quick one timer there Paso got
a piece of that pass then got more of
it here comes Holstrom with Paso two SC
Islanders strike [Music] [Applause] [Music]
shorthanded forces a turnover right at the blue
line on burns and then with a good daating speed
homst makes a good play give it to Paso get the
rander get the golender moving thinking about
whether he's going to get it back or not both
stay on side head up stick down and he goes up and
over makes no mistake about it Brendon didn't take
a chance for the goalie to lay his Pad across gets
Paso to to take a little look and the goalie he's
got to shift but they're uh they're scoring goals
and and and that was a problem with them over the
last couple years of not scoring five on five
that shot got quickly on net Soki made a save
on the rebounds fetch the COV couple of good
chances there for Carolina from anywhere and
everywhere and vet nikov lets that shot go defens
has got to turn around and take him out not worry
about the loose Puck the goal tender will handle
that so play continues but it's a delayed off
side and the her kanes have to clear the zone that
gives a chance for barzel to wind it up moving to
Horvat on the entry Horvat barzel barzel scores oh
beautiful give and go Bo Horvat not barzel three
[Applause]
nothing barzel I talked about barzel wants the
puck tonight little give and go with Horvat
get your stick down drive to the net and then
put it on the forehand up and over in the toy
department beautiful play by barzel he he's just
been on his game what a pass between the legs of
Burns and up and over the glove of the go tender
and man alive I mean it's just a thing of beauty
is the only way to describe it but I love the
fact that barzel wants to Puck and he's going
back and he's putting himself in position
to get a pass he still got 12 minutes left
to change that though well that was Barry Trot
Theory wasn't it Barry you listening that was
the way Barry had said not I'm not worried about
quantity I'm worried about quality yep make him
count this one coming around towards
Jaylen Chatfield Chatfield that shot
they score deflected in front sroa never saw
the shot from Jaylen chadfield and a quick
response for Carolina Puck goes all the way
around the boards I don't know if that goes
straight in or not Brendan but might have
been Mayfield in his [Music] pants tough to
tell yeah really tough to tell a whole bunch
of people in front see take another look at
it yeah judging by the reaction of Ilia he
thought it was going the other way definitely
changed Direction Nelson punched it up in the
air burns played it down Ang ball to the front
pal Mary driving and a save for Mora Thompson
buy some time gives to pageo pageo near the
line able to keep it on the blue paint Paso
to Romanov fresh on of the ice Ryan POF to the
outside pulock closing in save rebound there
fashing and Martin whack away and it can't
go AO got rid of it ahead for Anders Lee kanes
were in to change here's a chance for horac gets
an angle to the front and it's kept out by Ron as
crashing the goal was Sanders Lee brought to mive
humanity traveling towards the net didn't carry
the puck across the line Corbat tried to go all
the way in oh that that looked like almost
a little push him behind sent behind the net
it's Matt Martin that one deflects right through
the slot AO cross the ice bouncing Puck sennikov
with a step sikov head and a big time stop by
sokin and that shot just took the shot blocker
right off his foot Shane shot it wide back to
around for Martin in front it was blocked by
poock barzel knocked it out of the air to get
it away from the net then watch this particular
place roken goes left now he's got to come back
right and still has the wherewithal to spot that
puck from stall as gets it with his blocker
the big white blocker gets it right there and
another big save for the go tender shots are
3724 attempts are [Applause] 8135 as this one
is cleared out it's Carolina has more shots
on goal the Islanders have even attempted to
shoot tonight there's a chance from or and it
knuckled in change direction on SK and it's the
second knuckling Puck to deflect pass soken
tonight and with 741 to go so one two goals
both in defenseman and both transition last
Touch by an Islander yeah transition right
here not sure who that hits him
Jarvis and AO are tied up oh hit Alo
right SK Thompson moves it burn slips
down the boards to the net soken tried to play it
away and it stayed there and gave a
whack at it to Stephan Mason there a
goenda oh Horvat out for the faceoff win
and they score dropped off for kokami
with 1 second left on the power play and the
hurricanes have scored three straight to tie
it P does a great job but the Islanders lose the
one-on-one battle and nobody picks up cocen in in
front of the neck got lost off the face off after
moved away from Horvat pretty nice pass there from
snov yep very very good in in real tough and
just gets it right upstairs I mean you talk
about the toy department that was right there
boy that's tough when you win the face off and
then you lose the battle in behind your net little
Collision there this allows burs to walk in right
on beautiful opportunity for the Islanders doson
lets go of that shot low pad save by R Brady Shay
to AO cross the ice NES NES for AO walks in AO
scores Sebastian AO Carolina with four unanswered
to come from behind and beat the Islanders 43 in
overtime slaven [Music] cutting me his n and why
he's going a little pick action right in here
this is where there a miscommunication and then
just goes five hole with it and Islanders maybe
could have challenged a little bit but uh Paul
Mary needed to make the switch with his partner
nothing happened and AO didn't make any mistake